on va s'arrêter ce soir sur ce possible
tournant dans la lutte contre le virus
joe biden encore lui a pris tout le
monde de court la nuit dernière en se
disant favorable à la levée des brevets
sur les vaccins anti qu'ovide dans son
sillage l'om c'est l'union européenne
emmanuel macron se sont soudainement dit
eux aussi favorables c'est un peu
nouveau et même un peu surprenant quand
on sait qui hier encore dans l'hémicycle
du sénat le ministre cedrico trouvé que
la levée des brevets étaient une fausse
bonne idée
la france est elle un peu contrainte et
forcée de suivre un président américain
qui semble donner le là on va ouvrir
cette discussion avec nos invités dans
un instant d'abord les faits les
réactions avec gaspard flammes dans la
bataille pour une production de masse
des vaccins anti covit 19
les états unis apportent leur soutien
surprise à une suspension de la
protection des brevets par la voix de la
représentante au commerce catherine
taille s'étend et circonstances
extraordinaires appelle des mesures
extraordinaires
les etats unis soutiennent le
renoncement des protections de propriété
intellectuelle pour les vaccins anti
qu'ovide 19 pour mettre fin à la
pandémie
l'afrique du sud et l'inde avait déjà
fait cette proposition en octobre il
souhaitait une levée des protections
pour que chaque pays puisse produire des
vaccins sans se soucier des brevets et
ce jusqu'à ce que la majorité de la
population mondiale soit immunisée
l'union européenne elle ne s'était pas
prononcée favorablement mais la
déclaration récente des états unis
bouscule les choses et c'est pourquoi
nous sommes prêts à discuter de la façon
dont la proposition américaine de
dérogation sur la protection de la
propriété intellectuelle pour les
vaccins couvert peut permettre
d'atteindre cet objectif
changement de position également en
france
lors de l'inauguration d'un nouveau
centre de vaccination ce matin le
président macron dit vouloir suivre la
ligne américaine alors qu'il a toujours
été réticent sur le sujet oui nous
devons évidemment faire de ce vaccin
un bien public mondial je suis tout à
fait favorable à ce qu'il y ait en effet
cette ouverture de la propriété
intellectuelle vous m'avez entendu le
dire il ya un an quand nous avons lancé
l'initiative acta
véritablement permettre à ce que la
propriété intellectuelle soit levée
c'est au conseil général de l'om sait
que tout va se jouer des débats sur le
sujet ont déjà eu lieu avant même
l'annoncé de washington d'ici la fin du
mois de mai trois nouvelles réunions
doivent s'y tenir et avec nous ce soir
pour en parler david cormand bienvenue
europe
eurodéputée europe ecologie les verts co
président de la délégation europe
ecologie c'est du futur j'ai un peu de
mal au parlement européen et vous êtes
membre de la commission budget de la
commission marché intérieur jour olivier
babeau est également avec mon bienvenue
vous êtes économiste président fondateur
de l'institut sapiens et auteur de ce
livre le nouveau désordre numérique
comment le digital fait exploser les
inégalités avec le également à distance
car ils 1100 bienvenue vous êtes
économiste de la santé professeur à
l'école d'économie de paris et
chercheuse au cnrs et ronan le gleut est
avec nous vous êtes bienvenu vous êtes
sénateur et l'air représentant les
français établis hors de france
vous êtes membre de l'opex l'office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques et votre
profession initial ses examinateurs à
l'office européen des brevets merci à
tous les quatre d'être avec nous on en
reparlera du tournant insufflé par joe
biden d'abord le fond du sujet david
cormand pourquoi être pour pourquoi être
contre je voudrais qu'on essaye
d'expliquer nos téléspectateurs et vous
évidemment vous êtes pour la levée de
ces brevets je voudrais que nous dit
pourquoi il ya une raison j'ai envie de
dire éthiques
d'abord ces brosses et vaccins qui ont
été développés à une vitesse
hallucinante un vaccin habituellement
c'est plusieurs années autour de 10 ans
là ça a été fait en quelques mois encore
moins d'une année ça a été fait de
l'argent public
les années la migration américaine mais
au niveau de l'union européenne c'est
des dizaines de milliards qui ont été
mis à disposition pour accélérer cette
recherche
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
il ya beaucoup d'achats de vaccins qui
sont fait aussi avec de l'argent public
et donc là il ya quand même l'aspect
volaille et il n'y a pas de raison que
ce soit des intérêts privés qui
bénéficient qu'ils fassent bénéfices de
cette affaire alors même qu'elle vient
de dire il ya même pas l'argument de la
recherche
deuxième sujet fait qu'on est dans un
domaine de santé troisième argument pour
peut être trop long il ya la question
sanitaire
vous avez entendu il vous savez on sait
qu'à beaucoup de variants qui se
développent et si on veut éviter que ces
variants secret et se développe il faut
réussir à vacciner très rapidement tout
le monde pas seulement nous dans les
pays riches mais sur l'ensemble de la
planète puisque les gens circulent
le virus circule est donc un impératif
sanitaire au plus vite possible à
vacciner la plus grande partie de la
population mondiale pour que on tue la
capacité du vaccin a circulé donc là
la proportion de risque à ce que des
variances développe olivier babeau je
vous vois prendre des notes je crois
savoir que vous vous êtes contre la
levée de ces brevets est toujours dans
cette démarche de pédagogie vis-à-vis de
nos téléspectateurs pourquoi alors j'ai
bien conscience que si on faisait un
james bond ce serait le méchant avec le
chat sur les genoux vous êtes l'aimé
savoir ils en feront parce que sinon le
jazz band perd tout son intérêt
on est bien d'accord maintenant c'est
pas parce qu'une idée généreuse qu'elle
est vrai j'aimerais j'adorerais que ça
soit le cas malheureusement en économie
c'est pas c'est pas toujours le cas
qu'est ce qu'on vise on vise la
possibilité de vacciner beaucoup plus de
monde y compris dans grosso modo le sud
du globe
bon il est pas certain aujourd'hui que
ce soit les brevets qui soit la première
des choses qui nous en empêche
on a probablement un goulet
d'étranglement au niveau de la
production
la capacité à mettre en production ces
vaccins c'est vraiment ce qui nous
manque presque il y à des vaccins là
allez connu à la recette allez sur le
site internet d'ailleurs souvent des
producteurs donc c'est pas ça le
problème technologique déjà les jeux en
ligne par disons c'est c'est quel est
l'objectif c'est que voilà est-ce que ça
va réussir à réussir l'objectif c'est
pas certain malheureusement il ya des
problèmes qui sont et qui sont qui sont
différents la deuxième chose c'est une
question de pédagogie de faire une
pédagogie de la propriété intellectuelle
de washington en précisant qu'ils
étaient pour la levée ont quand même dit
une phrase important utilise
l'administration croit fermement au
protection de la propriété industrielle
et moi je crois que bon beaucoup de gens
qui militent pour cette levée
il y as pour eux une sorte de ba2
précédent qui se créera en disant mais
regardez vous voyez bien que on doit
lever les trucs alors il faut faire un
tout petit peu la médaille provisoire
oui provisoire et je suis d'accord que
la situation est vraiment exceptionnel
c'est vrai en ce sens un tout petit peu
de pédagogie économique et est
extrêmement rapidement si je fais je
suis un grand musicien c'est pas le cas
un grand musicien je fais de la musique
je travaille des années pour m'améliorer
je je je fais un morceau de musique est
formidable tout le monde reconnaît que
c'est formidable que il apporte vraiment
quelque chose à l'humanité et
culturellement et on va me dire non mais
tu n'aura aucune rémunération
parce que c'est tellement important
c'est un bien public que quelque part
d'ailleurs qui a été éduqué par
l'éducation nationale et donc quelque
part tu n'a fait que rendre alors est ce
qu'on pense que c'est juste et de
première chose et deuxièmement est ce
qu'on pense que c'est la meilleure
incitation parce que pour les
médicaments malheureusement c'est le
vrai problème c'est 10 à 12 ans et des
milliards d'investissements
quand vous êtes un pharmacien le risque
évidemment c'est qu'à terme il est moins
d'incitations pour d'incitation privé
parce que de temps en temps l'intérêt
privé fait indirectement l'intérêt
général ils m'ont à l'incitation demain
pour permettre un développement utile ça
c'est le grand argument avancé notamment
par les laboratoires karine 1100 y tient
cet argument ou pas il tient dans le
sens où il faut avoir un retour sur
investissement c'est la rémunération de
du temps passé et du risque pris de ne
rien trouver
maintenant ils skient cet argument est
un peu plus complexe parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'argent tu lis et un tennis
sur la table donc si vous voulez on
prend là bien clé l'argument de la santé
mais c'est un pas parce que j'ai dans
ces cas là il est médicalement aussi
devraient être gratuits mettant donc
constat un bien qui est purement
fabriqués de façon privée eh bien il est
normal en fait de récompenser celui qui
a pris ce risque avait en tranches et de
lui octroyer un brevet soudure et les
ramener ici il ya différents le premier
point c'est que ce n'est pas de l'argent
privé c'est de l'argent public donc à
quel moment faut-il mettre le curseur
que dirait que eh bien c'était un bien
qui appartient également au domaine
public
même s'il a été développé en interne
privé est-ce que cet argent public
aurait pu être investi dedans dans un
laboratoire purement public pour trouver
aussi rapidement avec sans ça je ne
prends pas donc il y as si vous voulez à
une espèce de de consensus a trouvé avec
les laboratoires et pour trouver ce
consensus il faut un peu vexé il faut un
peu dire
le brevet est tout seul des problèmes on
arrive à un consensus entre les deux
postes
quelques leaders aujourd'hui tel qu'il
n'y a pas suffisamment de vaccins et que
quand on est face à un monopole ça ça
compte economy class
quand on est face à un monopole
l'utiliser au lido coche à dire
plusieurs quel point des vaccins mais
pas suffisamment tiens on ne produit pas
suffisamment et d'autre même si on relit
ce qui lui c'est pas suffisant
ronan le gleut plutôt qu'une levée des
brevets vous avez déposé une proposition
de loi je crois pour demander la mise en
place de ce que vous appelez une licence
d'office oui alors c'est un métier mois
déjà 2
applique ça pose quand même une vraie
question de souveraineté
parce que pendant six mois le
gouvernement avec insistance qu'il
s'agisse du ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand qu'il s'agit s'agisse de
agnès paillard une hache et de cédric
haut et le 23 avril du président de la
république lui-même le 23 avril c'est
hier six mois ont répété avec insistance
que la levée des brevets s et l
expropriation et aujourd'hui parce que
joe biden le président des etats-unis la
maison et c'est un chapitre qu'on va
aborder je les dis on introduit sur je
voudrais juste d'abord que vous ne
répondiez sur le fond et notamment sur
votre proposition de loi très bien mais
écoutez il faut distinguer effectivement
ce qui est du ressort de l'expropriation
c'est à dire la levée des brevets de ce
que je propose c'est à dire
l'amélioration d'un système qui rend
dans le cadre de l' omc qui s'appelle la
licence d'office la licence d'office
c'est une une procédure qui existe en
droit français aujourd'hui que je
propose d'améliorer dans une proposition
de loi ou le ministre de la santé saisi
bercy dans un processus qui donne une
redevance eau breveté pourquoi parce que
il faut absolument permettre aux
entreprises pharmaceutiques de pouvoir
investir et faire de la recherche
or si on tue la preuve était interrompu
la recherche et il faut ce vrai on a un
petit soucis de connexion
c'est une mesure en n'ont alors pas très
très bien on va peut-être régler le
problème de connexion david cormand si
on tue les brevets ont tué la recherche
oui mais enfin ça a déjà été dit en
l'occurrence pour ça que la métaphore du
compositeur talentueux qu'eux
ce évoqués ne fonctionne pas parce que
là en l'occurrence le compositeur dont
vous parlez il a été financé en amont
pas seulement à l'école mais avec
l'argent public avec était revenu un
salaire et on lui a dit on donne de
l'argent que tu trouves pas un super
morceaux qui sera un succès au
hit-parade de toute façon on fond 40e'
on te garantis l'argent ce qui s'est
passé les laboratoires d'entre eux
parlent n'ont pas pris de risque au sens
financier du terme ça a été financée non
seulement la recherche mais on leur a
garanti le fait d'acheter avec une
opacité des contrats je reviens pas là
dessus mais enfin tout ça à contribuer
quand même à un système où s'il a un
problème de souveraineté
c'est un problème de souveraineté de
santé publique pour les citoyennes et
des citoyens et de la force des tête de
l'état avec des firmes qui en fait pile
elle gagne fin c'est nous qui perdons
dans tous les cas de figure elle s'en
sort donc l'aspect comment dire quand on
pourrait débattre paraza pas par
ailleurs de la libre entreprise etc
on n'est pas dans ce schéma là c'est pas
du tout je sais pas s'il y avait de
l'argent de vie mais il a eu énormément
d'argent public ronan le gleut 11 à
retrouver peut-être voulait répondre oui
mais goûter sans la recherche privée
c'est-à-dire celle des labos
pharmaceutiques
il n'y avait pas d' inventions tels que
aussi spectaculaire que sur les brevets
et les médicaments
et si on tue la recherche parce qu'il
faut bien comprendre que le système de
propriété intellectuelle a été vente
inventé à une époque où justement les
labos pharmaceutiques
ce volet l'invention du voisin et c'est
justement pour éviter d'avoir à voler la
lançons du voisin on a inventé un
système de propriété intellectuelle pour
permettre de récompenser la recherche
le système de récompense de la recherche
permet qu'un investisseur privé répond à
des objectifs privés et collectifs c'est
à dire un intérêt de santé publique et
donc il ne faut pas anéantir la
propriété intellectuelle car on n'est en
tirer la recherche
c'est pourquoi la licence dauphine ce
qui est prévu dans les textes de l'eau
et les accords à la fuite
malheureusement sur deux dans cette
affaire c'est bien aussi peut-être la
surpuissance des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques qui interroge qui pose
question c'est ce qu'on appelle le big
pharma est ce que ça nous fait peur
est-ce qu'on est un peu frileux avec ces
laboratoires pour essayer de les contrer
c'est pas moi qui pose la question ne me
regardez pas comme ça c'est
l'eurodéputée michèle rivasi au micro de
marie brémaud il ya quelques semaines
déjà
elle évoqué cette question écoutez c'est
qu'on est complètement soumis au diktat
des laboratoires et en utilisant les i
sens obligatoire c'est comme si si vous
voulez on contourne la volonté des
laboratoires mais on n'a plus le choix
il faut absolument me faire olivier
babeau est ce qu'on est soumis à un
diktat des labos on dit big is beautiful
en france begins frightening on a
toujours un petit peu peur de ces
grandes entreprises il ya beaucoup de
fantasmes et beaucoup de complotisme
d'ailleurs dont les anti vaccin n'est ce
pas se nourrissent moi je crois que si
on essaie de regarder les choses de
façon très très froid et sans avoir
d'intérêt jeu peu importe c'est de se
dire c'est quoi les incitations efficace
certes nationaliser les pertes et
privatiser les gains ça c'est un truc à
éviter mais enfin nationaliser les gars
et privatiser les pertes n'est pas
génial non plus donc effectivement il
faut quelque chose entre les deux donc
le système des brevets donc par exemple
quand vous inventez une molécule vous
mettez 10 12 ans vous en avez plein qui
tombe au panier c'est des milliards mais
vraiment sans strap des milliards
d'investissements et il ya un système
qui fait que pendant un certain temps
vous avez un droit exclusif au bout d'un
moment ça devient un médicament
générique et après la question c'est le
curseur sait à quel moment vous allez
mettre au curseur pour que vous dit bon
ça y est il s'est payé de ces
investissements sont incitation à
recommencer la recherche qui est
collectivement bonne pour l'humanité a
été suffisante maintenant on fait des
génériques que tout le monde doit
pouvoir faire et ça fait baisser le coût
et on en profite beaucoup donc voilà
c'est vraiment cette question là c'est
une alchimie subtile il faut il touché
avec des doigts tremblants donc vous
admettez qu'on les prend avec des
pincettes quand même ces grands
laboratoires et que et qu on les traite
et là elle
l'opacité des contrats résoudre cette
difficulté à avoir les contrats passés
entre l'europe et les grands
laboratoires c'est quelque chose de qui
qui semble à moi je ne suis pas juriste
je sais je ne sais pas mais la cause de
l'opacité
l'explication l'explication de facilité
je n'ai pas pensé il ya des explications
stratégie par exemple est ce que c'est
important pour du point de vue de la
concurrence entre les parcs à thème de
la concurrence et heureusement il y
aurait une seule grande pharma ils sont
ils sont plusieurs ils sont en confiance
ça en général le fait qu'ils sont en
concurrence c'est quand même le meilleur
est la meilleure garantie qu qu' aucun
ne s'impose trop par rapport à l'autre
sur les clients de karine 1100s quand
est-ce qu'on a peur de ses labos est-ce
qu'on est effectivement soumis un diktat
comme le dit michèle rivasi
à partir du moment où les liens
proviennent de laboratoires qui les
portent tellement on est soumis à l'état
donc ça ramène à la question qui a été
posée afin qu'ils exposent et des buts
et ce principalement qui est en
construction à une production de biens
au niveau européen est elle derrière
tout ça c'est un peu la question c'est à
dire qu'on est la stas addeski un petit
stylet qui seraient financés ont reçu de
l'argent aux puits
mais parce que en fait qu'il n'existe
pas au niveau public de la recherche
permettant de de faire produire al aqsa
ronan le gleut oui il faut qu'ils vous
permettez il faut quand même rappeler
qu' il n'est pas question de brevets de
vaccins c'est à dire que il est question
de brevets sur les techniques de
fabrication
c'est à dire que mes abba you and take
par exemple qui travaille avec pfizer à
des brevets qui sont des brevets
délivrés il faut distinguer la demande
de brevet du brevet délivré et bayod un
texte dispose de brevets délivrés sur
les techniques de production d'aérer le
messager ou des nanoparticules de
lipides et de la même manière
l'université d'oxford pour le vaccin
astrazeneca dispose de brevets
d'invention de techniques de fabrication
darren recombinants donc en fait c'est
la technique de fabrication qui sont
protégés par le droit de la propriété
intellectuelle
donc c'est pour ça que oui j'ai rien dit
donc c'est juste pour dire que quand on
parle de brevets ce sont des brevets de
procédés de fabrication ce ne sont pas
des réalités de brevets sur les vaccins
eux même si on va être vraiment très
précis et donc là il est vraiment
question en fait de la demande de
l'afrique du sud est de l'inde au top
2020 auprès de l'om c est le bon niveau
c'est à dire le niveau international
puisque la france seule
en l'occurrence ne peut pas décider de
la levée des brevets puisque tous les
accords sont au sein des accords alpiq
de l'om c'est de l'organisation mondiale
du commerce
en revanche ce que la france peut faire
seul et c'est le cadre de la proposition
de loi que j'ai déposé le 8 avril
d'envoyer sa route il ya un mois ce que
ce qu'est ce qu'une nation comme la
france perd seul c'est de décider la
licence d'office qui est une autre voie
qui permet à la fois de mieux protéger
pour la santé publique tout en
protégeant le droit de la propriété
intellectuelle est crucial pour l'avenir
parce que ici on n'est pas sur une
mesure pour l'immédiat mais qui nous dit
que l'année prochaine nous n'aurons pas
besoin d'inventer de nouveaux vaccins
aux deux nouveaux variants ou de
nouvelles pandémies à venir et donc il
faut préparer l'avenir il faut il faut
continuer à motiver les laboratoires
pour qu'ils continuent à investir
massivement dans la recherche les
motiver ou les brusquer david cormand ou
pas les deux sont en contradictoires
après les laboratoires dont on parle ne
se sent pas retrouver sur la paille à
l'issue de la crise sanitaire que nous
vivons d'ailleurs ils en ont ce sont
plutôt enrichi comme d'autres grands
groupes d'ailleurs qui travaillent vous
avez fait un livre sur numérique et
notamment dans le numérique et pose
d'ailleurs d'autres problèmes de
monopole
mais c'est un autre débat et la question
par rapport à tout ça au fond c'est la
même c'est pendant la puissance publique
comment l'intérêt collectif réguler
c'est surpuissant ce prix ville qui
s'organise s'agit pas d'être contre le
privé c'est à dire à quel moment ces
pleins pouvoirs ou cet excès de pouvoir
trop de place dans un état de droit où
dans une société vous sentez qu'ils ont
pris trop de pouvoir cesser j'allais
dire ces gros lobbies pharmaceutiques
pascal en tout cas observés depuis un an
on est privé de nos libertés
fondamentales de celui de libérer de ce
circuler librement de se voir il ya des
dispositions d'urgence sanitaire qui
atteignent ce qu'ils sont quand même des
fondamentaux absolue un peu plus
peut-être que la protection des
propriétés privées peut-être d'ailleurs
sur les droits fondamentaux qui fait que
nous sommes dans une démocratie est là
d'ailleurs les citoyens et citoyennes
français notamment je trouve accepté
avec le disponibles disciplinés et sens
des responsabilités et là tout d'un coup
on nous dit vous avez fait des efforts
depuis un an
vous avez renoncer à des droits
fondamentaux qui fait qu'on peut définir
qu'on est dans une démocratie pour des
raisons sanitaires
et là attention on va toucher à des
brevets a des intérêts groupes privés
qui se sont je le répète enrichi et ont
financé cette recherche avec notre
argent avec de l'argent public et
l'endiama nasa il faut pas y toucher vos
droits fondamentaux
il faut s'arranger vous comprenez ma
bonne dame par contre la propriété
privée de ces grands groupes
ça ça serait un drame absolu si on n'y
touche f1 il ya quand même un léger
déséquilibre par rapport à tout ça et un
déséquilibre olivier babeau c'est c'est
dur de jouer ma chance mais il faut
faire attention à ce que la
reconnaissance vient pas une accusation
on est bien content d'avoir un big
pharma a quand même pour nous avoir
apporté en quelques mois alors qu'on
attendait ça en un an et demi voire en
deux ans une solution donc déjà c'est
quand même très bien attention à ce
qu'ils aient pas comme bien des gens
malheureusement qui soutiennent que ça
il pas vers l'idée regardez ils
s'enrichissent à qui profite le crime
on sait donc en fait tout ça était une
manipulation et que s'ils ont fait ça
pour pouvoir mieux le vendre
les vaccins il ya quand même des gens
très sérieusement que nous explique sa
sur les lots sont pas très sérieux il le
dit sérieusement mais enfin on est entre
gens sérieux ici la personne ainsi
qu'ils pensaient donc essayer de faire
la pédagogie pour 10 rebonds
heureusement qu'il y avait ces gens là
quand on connaît un petit peu le monde
des affaires la pharmacie c'est un peu
comme l'automobile c'est dallas c'est ce
monde impitoyable
c'est à dire que il ya énormément de
concentration pourquoi en fait c'est des
entreprises qui se font bouffer par les
autres parce qu'elles n'ont pas la
taille critique parce qu'elles ont pas
réussi à avoir
médicaments avoir un blockbuster et donc
c'est la course aux investissements
celles ci sont de plus en plus dans
l'important avec un vrai drame si la
molécule à laquelle vous croyez finit
par ne pas marcher et là par exemple
pour sanofi pour le français c'est très
inquiétant je peux vous dire c'est à
dire que il ya en effet des entreprises
qui vont augmenter leur puissance
donc évidemment ceux qui ont les vaccins
qui marche le mieux ce qu'on rend pas
réussi dans la course ils vont faire
bouffer va y avoir de la concentration
alors oui à la fin ça peut finir
malheureusement par créer des formes de
monopole ou d'oligopole pour l'instant
ce n'est pas tout à fait le cas mais il
faut aussi se mettre à la place de ces
entreprises qui sont dans des business
alors en effet moi je suis je fais
partie des gens qui pensent que nous
avons une sans doute une médecine
beaucoup trop curative et pas assez
préventive
ça c'est absolument certain est que
quand on vend des médicaments on a
peut-être moins intérêt à développer une
médecine préventive mais bon ça c'est
aux pouvoirs publics mais honnêtement
aujourd'hui c'est un métier extrêmement
difficile avec des technologies qui
change
on fait plus les médicaments on va les
faire avec des biotech qui sont
complètement différentes
c'est comme l'automobile dire qu'il ya
une vraie comparaison affaire qui change
tout le business
donc c'est pas si facile voilà c'est pas
juste des gens assis sur des tas d'or
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça alors
sur ce dossier vous aurez aussi
remarquer qu'après le oui de joe biden
et ça va vous faire plaisir qu'on en
parle on en le bleu beaucoup se sont
soudain dit favorable à cette levée des
brevets à commencer par donc emmanuel
macron et pourtant hier ici même au
sénat lors des cadres lors des questions
au gouvernement sont ministres cedrico
trouvé que c'était une fausse bonne idée
et il nous expliquer pourquoi par a plus
b écouter est ce que une levée des
brevets de manière temporaire serait de
nature à répondre aux défis que vous
évoquez je ne suis pas sûr il est même
possible que ce soit une fausse bonne
idée pour la raison suivante d'abord le
premier problème n'est pas un problème
de brevet même si tous les étés brevets
étaient en accès libre
il faudrait il n'y aurait pas de
production supplémentaire pour les pays
du sud avant fin 2022
compte tenu de la complexité
industrielle que cela représente il faut
18 mois pour valider une usine
deuxièmement nous
ont nécessité de faire en sorte que les
industriels continuent à investir dans
la recherche pour développer les
réponses aux nouveaux variants si nous
leur retire ont la propriété
intellectuelle il y à des risques qu'ils
soient désinciter d'investir dans la
recherche sur les nouveaux variants
alors ça ça vous a énervé un ronan le
gleut donc je me tourne tout de suite
vers vous il ya un changement de pied
très clair à de l'exécutif français
écouter ce que dit federico hier dans
les mythiques du sénat qui quand même
l'enceinte du parlement de notre
relation la france en réalité le
gouvernement le dit avec insistance
depuis six mois puisque vous pouvez
parfaitement retrouver la position
exacte de du ministre de la santé
olivier vers en utilisant exactement les
mêmes termes dans les mêmes conditions
que cédric aussi hier au parlement mes
amis à ce panier rue taché de la même
manière et même le président de la
république lui-même le 23 avril dernier
donc avant-hier a dit exactement la même
chose et donc vous voyez que emmanuel
macron pas nuire une hache et veyran
cedrico tout le gouvernement le
président les ministres ont une position
depuis six mois et parce que aujourd'hui
joe biden le président des états unis
dit complètement l' inverse
parce que là c'est un retournement à
180° et bien ils suivent et vraiment ça
pose la question de la souveraineté
c'est à dire comment est ce que notre
nation la france peut-elle être vu du
point de vue de l'étranger comme une une
grande puissance dès lors qu'elle suit
aveuglément les états unis et et ai dit
le contraire de ce qu'elle disait la
veille
tout simplement parce que les états unis
ne change d'avis ou pour moi ça me pose
une question fondamentale sur la
souveraineté de la france qu'elle est
véritablement la place de notre pays et
qu'elle est quel regard or le monde sur
nous dès lors que nous sommes capables
de changer d'avis en un claquement de
doigts parce que tout simplement les
états unis changent d'avis d'autant plus
que
berlin fait savoir ce soir que le
gouvernement d'angela merkel lui veut
que les brevets reste protégé donc
l'allemagne ne suit pas joe biden la
france suit joe biden karine 1100 qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire et même au delà
de ça est ce que ce café byden est
absolument historique est ce qu'il est
en train de l'emmener avec lui tout un
tas de pays qui au départ ne voulait pas
de la levée de ces brevets alors il
étonnant ce retournement il porte
également étonnant je pense que joe
biden a envie de montrer un énorme
pendant aux états unis donc c'est pour
l'intérieur et pour l'extérieur de
l'acsa la question de lever les brevets
et qui a été vive hier par part c'est à
dire beaucoup parce que effectivement ça
demande tellement être en capacité de
produire au delà de lever du pro vers sa
demande de produire le vaccin lui même
donc on a aujourd'hui une autre
possibilité qui peut être associé en
fait on relevait élevé du mauvais ou du
moins une certaine attente de
rémunération laboratoire avec un
entrejeu 2,3 entre le brevet lui même et
la situation où il ya les laboratoires
ne resterait rien et a ajouté qu'il y à
la mise en place de par duco vaste qui
est la distribution gratuite des vaccins
puisque ce dont ils ont besoin
présentement les pays en développement
les pays qui ne peuvent pas en fait
acquérir le vaccin c'est d'avoir des
vaccins et c'est pas d'avoir à alain
brevets d'où ils sauront que faire à
l'affronter donc on est là dans une
situation assez paradoxale où noah il me
semble que ce qu'était énoncés
précédemment article on rentrait bien
dans cet acte
la complexité ou quoi mener une
réflexion sur comment assoupir en fait
les règles sur le brevet lié à ce
qu'elles sont totalement exceptionnel et
qui est lié au fait que les laboratoires
en rose que des sommes très importantes
qui est également lié ça a quelque chose
qui existe déjà et largement soutenue
par l'europe qui est la distribution de
vastes 1 pourquoi je suis complètement
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit nous les
écolos les verts au parlement européen
on avait demandé trois trucs la
transparence absolue sur les contrats de
kovacs le fait de livrer aux pays du sud
ont des délais pour les raisons
sanitaires que je disais en même des
missions et puis la levée des brevets
donc et c'est vrai aussi que la levée
des brevets en soi n'est pas la formule
magique qui suffit pas de lever les
brevets pour que dans votre cuisine chez
vous vous pourrez collier votre accent
parce que il y aura une nouvelle recette
sur internet c'est pas ça sur les chiens
je vais l'essayer sur ça mais c'est que
pour moi j'irai le changement de pied
bon ça c'est un problème de ce
gouvernement dont on a l'impression
quand même qui fait du zigzag dans la
crise sanitaire mais même de manière
générale et franchement je sois le
gouvernement pensait sincèrement que
fallait pas levé les brevets parce que
ça servait à rien c'est pas ma position
mais se défend et dont il fallait la
tenir
soit on pense que c'était pas le cas et
donc pourquoi en 24 heures ils ont
changé d'avis mais derrière la question
dont on parle moi ce qui me fout en
rogne plus que la question de la france
ou quoi
c'est là manque de leadership de l'union
européenne dans cette affaire nous
sommes la première puissance économique
du monde
nous sommes le premier marché du monde
mais nous sommes un nain diplomatique
nous sommes un an budgétaire et nous
n'avons pas de leadership en terme de
messages leur dire politique au sens
noble a adressé est donc là c'est les
états unis qui fixe le tempo et moi je
suis là parce que au niveau du parlement
vraiment un mot là-dessus
si nous étions un vrai frère entité
fédéraliste tout ce que dit baye donne
aujourd'hui il y aura une majorité au
parlement pour prendre cette position
politique là
et là à cause du rôle des états nations
au sein du conseil qui se contrôle se
jaugent se contrebalancent on est
complètement paralysée dans un moment de
crise économique de crise sanitaire de
crise écologique où il faudrait au
contraire assumer des positionnements et
il ya des majorités politiques au
parlement pour sa part au conseil et
c'est un eurodéputé qu'il dit merci
merci en tout cas à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est la
fin de cette émission se retrouvent
lundi à 18 heures et à 22 heures demain
bonjour chez vous 7h30 oriane mancini
recevra notamment emmanuelle wargon
ministre délégué chargé du logement
excellente soirée